[Music]
two days ago
i had this nice sinful life
and now it's a nightmare
if travel is searching
and home has been found
[Music]
i'm not stopping
i'm
who are you
[Music]
my name is sarah connor never seen one
like you before
almost human
i am human
why do you care what happens to her
because i was her
[Music]
how do we win we win
by keeping you alive
i'm going hunting
i've lived in a world of death
[Music]
i've watched people i've loved dying
some fast was a bullet
some not enough left to bury
all these years i've kept my secrets
but the time has come to face my past
[Music]
and if it comes looking for me
they will welcome death
[Music]
is coming
yeah there's nothing they can do to stop
it
[Music]
i think women can do anything just
because they can doesn't mean they
should
have so many talents
[Music]
i'm just a decoy snack that's just the
way you make me
outstanding angels
[Music]
you have a new client who is she i can't
sleep at night
i'm the lead programmer on a product
that can revolutionize the power
industry but there is a possibility it
can be weaponized
elena we need to go you know
no i'm james
who are you i'm bosley
welcome to the towns and agencies we
exist because traditional law
enforcement can't keep up i don't like
that
boy you guys are like lady spies
james former my six oh god what did you
do to spend
i compressed his carotid and
deoxygenated his brainstem well that
sounds
painful don't worry he's gonna wake up
unless he doesn't
sabina runs the ground game
see i know stuff let's get the weapon
before it becomes every bad guy's
favorite new toy
take her to the closet gear her up we're
gonna need some wigs
toys feisty
clothes ah we're still in the first
closet
there's another closet oh my god
oh man let's just stop the touching some
of this
blows up
[Music]
i love phosphorus jane are you flirting
with a handsome nerd
[Music]
how'd that feel because it looked like
it felt really good that felt nice
[Music]
good morning angels good morning charlie
[Music]
we have excellent news the matchmaker
has found you an auspicious
match it is decided
come and sit down
[Music]
it is what is best for our family
[Music]
yes i will bring honor to us all
quiet
[Music]
composed
graceful
[Music]
disciplined
[Music]
these are the qualities we see
in a good way
these are the qualities
[Music]
it is my duty to vote
[Music]
you must really like fishing mr
president it's
cold out here sorry anything to get out
of dc for a while
mike i'm selecting you for secret
service director
congratulations i'll give him my best
shot sir
i got to beware what is that
are they bats the crowns are gross
don't move don't move i'm coming to you
you're coming at your bar get them in
the water down
i got you going under dive deep
there's been an assassination attempt on
the president mike fanning
you're being charged with the attempted
murder of the president of the united
states
the president's top guardian angel has
fallen
don't you see that i'm being set up
you have a collect call from mike
tommy's frozen we've been getting death
breaths there's somebody else behind us
it wasn't me
the present's not safe then to try and
finish the job
and i'm not gonna stop until i prove who
did this
[Music]
how did you find me i want security for
the president how do you think
dad i need your help
don't worry about finding me
[Music]
not you
[Applause]
[Music]
the situation in the pacific
is far worse than reported
pearl harbor is the greatest
intelligence failure
[Music]
in american history
the japanese are planning something
bigger
so what's the target we believe it's
midway
washington disagrees
washington is wrong
today we're gonna be underdogs
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
today we prove the american navy isn't a
joke
you'll remember this moment for the rest
of your life
[Music]
we've passed on all we know
a thousand generations live in younow
but this is your fight
[Applause]
[Music]
hahaha
we'll always be with you
[Music]
no one's ever really gone
[Laughter]
[Music]
your father died protecting this city
he taught you to follow your conscience
in an often cruel world
what happened we're staying 18 years how
many cops
hate why were they here they responded
to a robbery
automatic weapons two shooters we have
training how old were you when your
father's captain king
i asked for you for a reason i will find
them
can we just kill hops we need to run we
gotta move fast cars not ours plates are
stolen
if we don't catch these guys in the next
three or four hours they vanish
how you gonna do this close the item
there are 21 bridges in and out of
manhattan shut them down
three rivers closing four tunnels block
them
stop every train and loot the subways
then we flood the island with blue
man none of this makes sense the bid was
for 30 keys we walked into 300.
they'll have to open manhattan by
morning eight dead policemen is one
thing but the stock market losing
billions of dollars is quite another
this whole thing is filthy you know what
i mean you got to be to move 300 kilos
of cocaine
oh my god is going on here i just need
the truth that's all
they told me it was fearless the guy
kills cop killers
sees his dad and every cop who dies
[Music]
they're not gonna escape the silence
you're the only cop tonight who speaks
first and shoots seconds
and we'll find out why the night
happened
gotta represent
[Music]
yeah be cool be nice i'm stu how do you
do
compton i'm lapd let's go
what do you have a more specific address
captain
stop yelling neighborhoods that's not
how uber works
hi hi ladies what the hell is going on
you selected the uber pool option over
what
ladies official police business is that
even real get out of the car
official police business she's going to
see a friend
oh i am not touching that it's a baby
gun it allows you to fire it while
crying
is this an uber angry duck dad why are
you laughing
oh dude
done you shoot it you'll blow up their
car he kidnapped me
doesn't freaking jaws exactly just like
jaws it's gonna work ready we killed
some people
just defeat him
i got this hello operator we need help
someone's trying to murder us
hello operator we need help
you still talking to your friends it's
complicated many a deer
has to fall
[Music]
anthony this is uh martha and bethany
this is spencer's grandfather nice to
meet you
morning sorry to barge in on you you're
not barging he's barging milo walker
did you guys see spencer
i think he went back in we gotta go get
him are you
out of your mind we haven't even picked
our guys yet oh
he's just talking all right
spencer huh what who are you oh my god
you're spencer's grandfather are we in
florida
and you milo walker did i die and turn
into some kind of a
small muscular boy scout are we dead
bethany no no no rich
i'm the old fat dude this can't be
happening
my hip sure feels good now look at my
thighs look at your tires look at my
thighs
okay we have some issues here the game
is busted it was a game
i'm not here i don't want to be yet
welcome to jumanji
this next event joke is even more
challenging and remember the future of
jumanji is in your hands
i have one important question who is
jumanji
is that barbara's boy we're gonna die we
did die are we in hell i knew it oh my
god
this is a whole new thing let me know
you got to have eyes in the back of your
head
what in the sam hill
what the hell is this it's your
strengths and weaknesses smoldering
intensity it's this stupid face you make
huh
what's going on you having a heart
attack breathe breathe his whole left
side is shutting down eddie
[Music]
you